all right so this presentation we're
going to go over the basics of one of
the kingdoms of life that we don't
really know a whole lot about still and
this kingdom of life is in the purple
bubble in the middle of the diagram the
Protista even though the Protista
there's they're really unique and
there's a lot of that we don't quite
understand about them their evolutionary
importance isn't is incredible from the
bubble diagram you can see that we think
that Protista gave rise not just to
animals but also to fungus and plants so
there are hugely important category in
the evolution of life on Earth and let's
go over some of their basics
so in general here's a little collage of
a few microscopic Protista but in
general Protista are mostly aquatic and
I say mostly because there are some when
we get to the fungus-like protists there
are some that do live on land but for
the most part their aquatic you'll find
them rivers lakes streams some kind of
body of water now one thing that is true
of all Protista is that they are
eukaryotic however their cell is its
eukaryotic it has a nucleus however they
may or may not be UNITA most of them are
most of them are one celled organisms
however when we get to some of the
plant-like protists though you'll
recognize kelp kelp is probably one of
the more common proteases it can grow
really really really large hard to the
feet tall therefore being multicellular
but most of them are unicellular when it
comes to reproduction they're they're
pretty adaptable some Protista can
simply divide themselves in half like
you see in the picture here bacteria did
this as well binary fission other
Protista will create little buds and
kind of branch off little buds of itself
and others will actually will actually
join with the neighbor and exchange bits
of bits of DNA so they're very diverse
in pretty much everything that they do
including how they reproduce when it
comes to how they obtain the nutrition
again they're really diverse most of
them are heterotrophic and by
heterotrophic we mean again that they
have to consume something they have to
and so we're going to show you that some
of these proteases are actually very
fierce predators now again they're
microscopic fierce predators hunting
other microscopic organisms some however
are autotrophic autotrophic and can do
photosynthesis some of them are
decomposers the decomposers are a type
of heterotroph because they get their
food from means other than
photosynthesis and some even are a
parasitic
they're parasites and they live off of a
host so there's a whole wide variety and
so because they vary so greatly into the
analogy that's often made about
proteases they're kind of like the
kitchen junk drawer you know that one
drawer in your kitchen everything else
is organized except for that one drawer
the drawer next to it organized that's
got the silverware in it but you are
next to it organized that has office
supplies in it but we all have that one
junk drawer it's got some office
supplies but it's also got just a bunch
of things in it that you can probably
throw away batteries that don't work
mixed up with batteries that do work
half-empty roll of tape and empty roll
of tape broken pens and with no cap on
it a pencil with no eraser we all have a
junk drawer and that's kind of the the
Protista right there and that they they
don't quite fit we don't if we don't
quite know what type of organism it is
now let's throw it in the Protista
category so what we do know is that
there are three main categories of
protists that we're going to go over
those three a little in a little bit
the animal-like Protista that behave
like animals the plant like Protista
that again behave like plants and the
fungus like that behaved like fungus so
we're going to go over those starting
with animal life
so here we have a picture of an animal
like Leticia this is an amoeba an amoeba
is a very common animal-like protists
that you may have seen before but
animal-like protists are also called
protozoans also known as a KA also known
as protozoans and because their animal
like they have to be heterotrophs
there's no photosynthesis in the animal
like Protista so animal like are
heterotrophs and and some of them are
fierce predators some of them are
parasites and because they live off of a
host they very well can even cause
disease that would make them a pathogen
and so we classify these animal like
Protista into three sub categories based
on how they move and this is pretty
straightforward once we start looking at
the three categories well since we have
the picture of the amoeba up here we
might as well start with category number
one the pseudo pads now pseudo is a
prefix that means false or fake pods
means foot if you're a podiatrist you
work on the feet so a pseudo pod
literally means they have a false foot
and so that's how these things move the
picture shows an amoeba and amoebas
don't really have any specific shape
they just look like a blob of cytoplasm
and when they're moving it's kind of
it's kind of neat to see them move when
they move their cytoplasm just oozes to
the left and then the rest of the cell
flows into it and then it'll change
direction it'll start oozing upward and
then the rest of the cytoplasm will flow
into it then it might change directions
and ooze to the left and the rest of the
cytoplasm will flow into it and so every
time it oozes it branches out a little
piece of cytoplasm and in the picture
you can see that that is called a pseudo
pod amoebas are great examples of that
how they feed is by simply facial
cytosis here we have a fairly simplistic
animation of a cell swallowing a a green
square and so this is an example of
facial psychosis because faiza cytosis
amoebas just kind of look like blobs of
cytoplasm and so they just slowly
surround their victim their prey they
swallow it up and it's digested by
enzyme here we have an animation of an
amoeba swallowing up a what looks like a
Paramecium which we'll talk about in a
moment but notice how its cytoplasm just
kind of branches out from various parts
these branching outs of the cytoplasm
are its false
feet those are its pseudo pods another
type of animal-like protists that are
called flageolet well that based on
their name flageolets you should be able
to tell that they move with the help of
a flagella
here we have a flageolet known as
Giardia and you can see the the flagella
dangling down in this picture well I put
grd up there because actually Giardia is
a fairly common intestinal problem that
can cause diarrhea if you ingest Giardia
in contaminated water
well the Giardia can grow and cause
diarrhea
another example of a animal-like
protists oh that moves with the help of
a flagella is the bottom picture the
trim panel soma this thing lives inside
of the gut of a tsetse fly
and so they imagine spending your entire
life inside the intestines of a fly well
pretty much your entire life inside the
intestines of a fly and so when a tsetse
fly bites a human it will inject this
trim panel so m'a into your into your
blood and that's kind of where the trim
panels oma divides multiplies reproduces
and then along comes another TT fly
bites a human and sucks it back up and
they're able to carry out their life
this way but this can cause a disease
known as sleeping sickness which can
actually be fatal and if you're curious
about sleeping sickness go ahead and
google it you'll find lots of it not get
information about and then the third
group of animal-like Protista are the
ciliates
and because they're called ciliates you
should be able to imply that they move
with the help of cilia here we have an
animated picture of some cilia wiggling
back and forth and you can see that
there are hundreds of them so it's not
like the flagella the flagella may only
have one or two or three or four
flagella
but the ciliates have hundreds and
hundreds of cilia and they wiggle and
because there's so many of them they're
fairly quick and because there's so many
of them they're pretty acrobatic they
can twist they can turn they can stop on
a dime and quickly change directions
so here we have a picture of a more
well-known ciliate known as paramecia
and notice going around the edges of
this picture are tiny little extensions
sticking out these are the cilia and so
that's how they move and these are the
animal-like their animal-like because
again they're heterotrophic they're
there they can be predators as well
I already mentioned the tsetse fly
causing sleeping sickness but I also
wanted to mention another one and this
is one that we saw the other day when we
looked about when we went over the the
notes on the immune system this this
little parasite right here is called
Plasmodium it's an animal like Batista
and it can cause the disease called
malaria the vector I just wanted to
throw this word out there again because
we talked about this in the immune
system notes the vector is what spreads
a disease so mosquitoes don't cause
malaria Plasmodium does but the
Plasmodium this little parasite in the
picture lives inside of the mosquito and
when a mosquito bites a person the
mosquito injects the Plasmodium into the
person and so here we have a picture of
that happening and a mosquitos biting a
person and injects that Plasmodium into
the person's blood the Plasmodium will
then migrate into your liver where it
will develop and grow lay some eggs and
eventually the Plasmodium will reproduce
and spread and start to kill off use
your your red blood cells and start to
reproduce with the help of your red
blood cells and end up killing your red
blood cells kind of similar to what a
virus does remember how viruses cause
cells to explode that's kind of what you
see happening in this picture and now
that your blood is teeming with this
Plasmodium along comes another mosquito
bites you sucks up the Plasmodium and
then flies out and flies around and
bites another person so some of these
these protozoans can again cause disease
and these are some of the effects of
malaria in humans fever vomiting
eventually a person can go into a coma
and die if they're not given anti
malarial drugs
let's change directions here and go into
the plant like Protista well what makes
them plant like I hope it's pretty
obvious what makes them plant like first
of all these are also known as algae so
for those that might have a fish tank
you know all about algae every so often
you got this layer of green slime on
your fish tank and you got to clean the
fish tank but what makes them plant like
is the fact that they're photosynthetic
and now how come we don't consider them
real plants then well real plants are
are multicellular and plant-like
protists that are for the most part
unite cellular plant-like protists also
don't have roots leaves roots or leaves
and so for these reasons we called
Protista plant like we call LG plant
like and so the the different types of
algae are classified by the kind of cell
wall that they have and what their cell
wall is made from now we're not going to
go into the components of the cell wall
we're just going to go over a few of the
more common groups of plant-like
protists starting with
starting with the EULA noids the EULA
noids also called you greener these are
kind of neat because they're kind of
animal-like they're animal-like and that
they have a flagella and can swim around
they can even capture their own food but
their plant like and that they're green
they got chloroplasts in them so
therefore they do photosynthesis so
they're kind of interesting in that way
and that their plant like and animal
like but because they do photosynthesis
we put them in the plant like category
and not the animal like category
and here we have an animation of the you
grenade just swimming around you can see
at its back-end that there's a flagella
pushing it forward as it swims but
notice that the color green implies the
presence of chlorophyll so it's able to
do photosynthesis see that red spot at
the front it's got a red spot used to
detect light and so it will sense bright
light and swim that direction because if
there if it swims into bright light it's
able to do photosynthesis better another
category I want to mention of plant-like
protists that are the dinoflagellates
and I want to mention these because of
their huge importance in the world of
ecology they have a huge role in plant
era I'm sorry they have a huge role in
ocean ecosystems from the picture here
we have a food chain well look at the
base of a food chain it says plant
plankton well it should say plant like
plankton plant like because plankton
earns actually plants but they're plant
like because they do photosynthesis in
the middle of the ocean where there's no
land just open water for miles and miles
and miles
we have thriving ecosystems in the
middle of the ocean even though there's
no plans to do photosynthesis
there's plant-like protists to do
photosynthesis and these are the
dinoflagellates they make up the basis
of most ocean food chains and ecosystems
and so here they are I mean this is
highly magnified right here that are
kind of creepy looking but also notice
in a in the same way they're kind of
interest intriguing and beautiful look
at so this is a picture of a
dinoflagellate and it's able to do
photosynthesis and release oxygen it's
also part of the foundation of most
ecosystems in the oceans
and the third group of plant-like
protists I want to mention are my
favorite the diatoms my favorite because
of just how geometric geometrically
pretty they are these pictures that you
see shows some diatoms and what's unique
about them is that they have a glass
like shell that surrounds them and so
because of that shell you can see that
they just have these really incredible
complex geometric patterns and they're
just really neat to look at they're also
whoa there goes the bell right now so
that will pass in just a moment and so
they are green and have chlorophyll and
do photosynthesis and actually they're
pretty much the kings of photosynthesis
they produce about 50% they alone the
diatoms alone produce about 50 percent
of Earth's oxygen you know we typically
think of plants as being the true
masters of photosynthesis but when you
look at the diatoms alone they make
about half of Earth's oxygen through the
process of photosynthesis so I think
these are really neat examples of
plant-like protists
so the next category I want to mention
is the final one the fungus-like protist
so what makes them fungus-like well what
makes them fungus-like is that they're
their decomposers they absorb nutrients
from whatever it is that they're growing
on if they're growing on for instance a
fallen tree
well they release enzymes and absorb
nutrients directly from that fallen tree
so they're decomposers very much like
fungus or decomposers and a few things
that are interesting about them is they
go through these series different stages
of their life their early stage they
release spores the spores actually have
little cilia on them are able to swim
around so these things even though they
live on dry land if their spores land in
damp soil this the the spores have cilia
and can swim around a bit and then
eventually develop into some of the
organisms that you see in the pictures
so there's two big categories of
fungus-like protists I want to mention
and we're just going to mention a few
brief facts one category are called the
slime molds and that's what you see
pictured here the one on the bottom is a
really neat example the slime mold
actually grows out and it pulses almost
like it has a heartbeat and what's neat
about it like it says it's a single cell
it's a single mass of cytoplasm so this
thing can grow rather large and it's
literally only one cell with us with a
pulsating cytoplasm and what makes it
again fungus-like is that it's a
decomposed or an animal-like and that it
has spores on it that can swim around
and at an early stage
and the other category I want to mention
our water mold and water molds I want to
mention because like it says it can be
parasitic but water molds I really want
to mention because they have historical
importance they caused the disease known
as potato blight which was the leading
which was the the main factor behind the
Irish potato famine so when the Irish
potato famine hit in the 1800s the Irish
their crops became their crops the
potato crops they were growing became
infected with a water mould and you can
see pictures of the infected potatoes of
what the potatoes look like when they're
infected with this mold and so the vast
majority of poor lost their number one
source of food potatoes and so we had
there was mass starvation in Ireland at
this time and so this caused a lot of
Irish to emigrate and move to other
places for in search of a better life
and this led to a mass emigration of
Irish into the United States so the
potato blight has has historical value
in that it it's can again that's
parasitic and it can it has as a history
with with disease in in humans
and I just wanted to throw this picture
in here I just thought it was a really
powerful tribute this is a tribute in in
Dublin and again it's a tribute going
back to the Irish potato famine and
again just so a way to remember that
time in in Ireland's history and
hopefully you know try not to repeat the
same Acts and so when we finish up with
our notes I'm Proteas though one reason
why they're really important is in the
world of evolution again they they are
they're so diverse and what we see is a
shift from unicellular life to
multicellular life and here's what we
mean some protists are a single cell and
they live by themselves here we have a
single-celled Euglena it's got a
flagella it does photosynthesis it can
swim around but we also see a shift we
also see protists they live in colonies
here we have a group of cells called
Volvox this is a group of Protista but
what's interesting is that this is not
one big organism this is made up of many
organisms all living as a colony now
what's interesting about this colony it
says there's no specialization so it's
not like one group of cells does one job
another group of cells does another job
another group of cells does another job
it's not like that they're all
independent acting but they live in this
multicellular arrangement so what we're
seeing is a transition of life from one
cell to multi-cell and finally we see in
protists that we see multicellular life
kelp is a great example can grow
hundreds of feet tall and kelp has cells
that are specialized to do very specific
jobs so the so the evolutionary
importance of Protista is really they
are the ancestors to multicellular life
because when we look at the plants the
animals and the fungus they're all
multicellular for the most part there
are a few one celled fungus out there
but for the most part plants animals and
fungus are all multicellular and we
think they evolved from Protista which
are mostly unicellular and say mostly
because there
there looks like there's a transition
from one cell life to multicellular life
when we study Protista
this might be a good a good place to
pause the video if you want to do some
review here it's just a little flowchart
kind of illustrating some of the major
points that we talked about so if you
wanted to spend more time on this hit
the pause button maybe jot it down or
Dilly's hit the pause button and review
it because i'm going to move on and here
we are we have the end so the practice
quiz all of these questions can be the
answers can be found in the video that
we just watched so hit the pause button
and try to answer some of these
questions jot the answers down on a
separate piece of paper I'd be happy to
check your answers before or after class
so good luck and I hope this was helpful